Candid Truth.
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. Since we started
this ministry 11 months ago, God's just
been blessing. Doors have been open in
so many ways. We actually went to
Bolivia to got to to get to speak. We've
been to Hawaii. We've been to
California, California, different parts
of the US. And we continue to pray for
God to open up those doors. Actually,
maybe you guys never even knew that we
actually go places physically and speak
at churches. So whatever church you are,
whoever you are, if you are blessed by
these messages, if you think your youth
and young people need to hear these
messages and the old people too, um,
about the dangers of media, the UFO
deception, the dark origins of holidays,
or any of these topics that we talk
about on this program, go to our
website,
candidruth.org. You can click the little
link that says booking. You'll see our
calendar, where we're speaking, what
dates we're open for, and the price it
takes to get us there because we can't
pay out of pocket to go speak places.
But, uh, we do this because we feel
called to to shed the light, to expose
darkness, and go wherever we get
invited. So,
actually, we have been communicating
with a pastor from Kenya, and there's a
church in Australia. Both of these
churches can't afford to book us, to fly
us out there, to put us somewhere to
stay, and we're not trying to make
money. We just we don't have money to
fly ourselves out there and give a
presentation and come back. So if any of
you feel led to give give to this
ministry, you can do so by going to our
website. If you go to candidtruth.org,
we got many different ways you can give
digitally. We thank you guys so much for
those of you who are donating to this
ministries so that we can stay alive.
God has provided ever since we started
this 11 months ago. But um the church in
Kenya is actually a Pentecostal church.
a pastor who says he believes in the
Sabbath and he wants our messages to
come out there to um help spread truth
about media and all these things. And
another church in Australia who is a
small church, but they want to get us
out there and and share this with
people. Someone's asking about Patreon.
We do have a Patreon now. I'll put the
link in the description. It it should be
easy to find. It's probably
patreon.comcannedtruth official. We have
not advertised it yet because we are
just two people trying to keep this
thing going. And I know a lot of Patreon
people, they offer all these perks for
different tiers and stuff and we at this
moment can't do that. But if you want to
go to Patreon and donate that way
because it's just easier to keep up with
to have it automatically taken out of
your bank each month, we would love
that. And so please go sign up for that.
Nobody's on there yet. Everybody gives
these other ways because we haven't
promoted Patreon yet. We're trying to
get that thing established. It's ready.
It's up and going if you want to go
there. Um, but in the future, we will we
want to offer perks and things like
that. We are also trying to What town in
Australia? I'm actually not sure. That
was a few months ago that they invited
us, but we forgot where that is right
now. Um, sorry. A subscriber to the
channel really wants to get us out
there.
Um, also we are going to be making more
literature. If you guys remember Aby's
Strange Dreams book, that book got
published because of you guys donating.
We got 2,000
books printed. And if you guys go
through the videos, you'll see like the
delivery guy delivering all those 2,000
books to the house. That was in January.
It's now May, and I'm down to 100 books
out of 2,000. The majority, 90% of those
books were requested through mail. So,
somebody would order 20, somebody to
order 50 to give out to the kids at
their church or whatever. I haven't
hardly given out just given random
people that those books. I take them
everywhere I go and when I see the
opportunity, I do give them out. But the
majority, 90% of those books were
requested by people even in other parts
of the world, but it's too expensive to
send the book. It cost $20 to ship one
little kids book to Canada. So, um, we
have digital PDF versions if you guys
want that. We have the video version on
our site if you go to videos. I'm just
trying to fill you guys in on what we're
doing as a ministry because I think
maybe some people think we just sit
around in our PJs and research on the
internet and and go live and talk about
it. And that is some of it, but
definitely not the majority of it. We
are rarely home it seems like anymore
traveling. We've been we were gone for
two weeks and uh we're just always on
the road
and that's why some of the videos don't
come out as often. Another thing we have
a lot on our plate being two people
trying to keep content coming. We want
to hire somebody and we need to hire we
need to hire somebody. We need to hire
somebody for our social media so that we
can get videos on Tik Tok. There is a
whole world of people, young people on
Tik Tok, and there's no can of truth on
Tik Tok. If we could get somebody to
edit our videos into one minute or three
minute or whatever Tik Tok allows and
start blasting stuff on Tik Tok, that
would be amazing. Our Instagram, we
hardly touch it. We don't have time to
make social media post. Most of our
stuff is live videos like this. We need
somebody to do social media. We need um
somebody to What were you going to say?
video editing. Video editing because a
lot of people this day and age don't sit
around and watch one to five hour long
streams. So, let's be clear real quick.
We're not actually putting out like an
ad for a job really. We're actually
wanting your help. We are looking to
grow because we need the help, but we
also need your funding, your backing
behind us being able to do so. Yeah, we
have somebody in mind actually that's in
the family. We want to keep it in the
family. Somebody that understands what
we're talking about, that can uh chop
out parts of the videos that we need and
put the text on there and and somebody
that can illustrate with B-roll and
stuff that makes sense. We tried to hire
somebody on Fiverr from another country
and it didn't go well. So, we need your
support is what we're saying. And we
love you and thank you guys for those
that are giving. But we want to grow and
we want we want these truths to get out
far and wide and on all platforms.
Rumble, Bitshoot, all that stuff. We're
not on any of it. We're only on Facebook
and then or we're only on YouTube and
then we put some stuff on Facebook and
then very rarely put stuff on Instagram.
But that's because the formats are all
different. You got to have shorter
videos for Instagram reels. We don't
really make reels. We need somebody to
do that. So, all that to update you guys
on what's going on. And let's get into
this topic because ever since we started
the ministry, we've had a lot of people
reach out to us. Sometimes it's, "Hey,
did you guys see this?" Or, "Hey, you
guys should talk about this." But lately
when we've been talking about these
truths of what's going on in our world,
that Jesus is coming soon, that this
thing is wrapping up,
more and more we're getting questions
about what do I do about this sin in my
life. I'm enslaved to this thing. I hate
this thing. And yet I keep falling into
it like a dog returning to its vomit.
How do I get out of this snare, this
trap that Satan has placed for me that
Satan is is so crafty? He knows exactly
how to get you. He's got a tackle box
full of bait. And if you're not into
this, he's got this, you know, and if
you're not into horror movies, he's got
princess movies or whatever it is. He's
got all the If you're not into drugs,
games, you know. So he's reaching every
age demographic with different different
varieties of bait all that are these
sinful addictive habits, right? So how
do we overcome?
Well, again, I we want to be able to
talk about overcoming all kinds of sins,
but tonight we're really wanting to
focus on addiction, just to be clear
about that. So when we think about
this, my brain, because both me and
Mikey have dealt with
addiction, thinks of quite a few things.
Um, I know a lot of people in the world,
um, especially in the Christian world,
can give you a lot of just
very kind of Christian phrases that are
supposed to help you just just
surrender. Yeah. Cliche stuff. They're
all cliche. They're not actually all
that helpful. And I'm not saying I I'll
say I don't think those things are not
true. No, they're true. But how do you
make how do you make that practical? You
know, exactly. You have to be more real
than that. It's not just someone could
tell you, oh, just just surrender, just
pray, just do this, just do that. No,
it's not just that. We're going to break
that down a little more. Um, and I
honestly going through um you'll learn
what what kind of addiction. And I'll
get into some of that,
but I was in a place I had to have such
real application, such real downto-
earthth help um that having someone tell
me something like that actually was kind
of like a slap in the face. They weren't
being with you in the moment. They were
not, you know, how we're supposed to
carry each other's burdens.
They weren't doing that at all. Um and
so they weren't hearing me out. they
weren't caring, whatever it was, they
could not help me. Yeah. Um, so when
someone is
that, I guess they're trying to cloak
themselves in Christianity, but they're
not really What's the verse? There's
like an entire story where um someone
said, "I'll just pray for you." Oh,
yeah. Instead of helping you. So, it's
in it's in James and it's talking about
faith without works is dead. And it
says, you know, if you see somebody
hungry and poor and naked, don't just
say, oh, well, uh, go be fed and clothed
and be on your way. No, you have to
actually take initiative. So, yeah, pray
with them. But then it's up to us to
help them, clothe them, feed them,
whatever it is. We are supposed to
follow up our faith with works. Faith
without works is dead. So for anybody
that's triggered by that, read James. I
think it's chapter 2 or chapter 4. Um,
it goes into this whole thing about how
even the devils believe and tremble, but
they are not going to be saved. And how
Abraham, you know, it was his works that
made him righteous or whatever. Noah, he
could have just said, "Well, I got
faith. I'm going to be saved when the
rain comes." No, his works. He had to
put into action, build that boat like
God told him to do. Yeah. Some people, I
don't know if you've heard this, but
righteousness is actually learning right
doing to follow after God and become
like him in character in in all your
ways. And so,
um, that's what you strive to do. But
when we're talking about addiction for
me, I don't know, do you have a slide
next that's to break it down? I do want
to just show that this is God's
three-step plan. We've heard of the
addiction recovery seminars where they
got the 12step program. God's plans are
much simpler. And I I'm not saying that
12step programs don't work. I didn't I
didn't go through that. I went through
God's three-step program. I was
addicted. I was addicted to marijuana
and alcohol. Anybody that doesn't think
marijuana is addictive, you're in
self-denial.
Every day that me or my friends didn't
have it, we were irritable. We spent the
whole day looking for it. It is an
addiction. Alcohol. I was literally
nauseous until I got alcohol daily. And
every day I thought I could overcome. I
won't do it today. I fell for it because
Satan would send some minion in the form
of my friends to knock on my door and
they would provide it. You know, I I
thought, well, if I don't pay for it or
I don't buy it myself. Look, misery
loves company. People love to get high
with someone else. That I was homeless
by choice for a year and every day I was
high and drunk. I didn't have to have
money. When you have friends, that's all
you need, quote unquote friends. And so,
I had to reach a place. New Year's 2023,
if anybody's heard my testimony, you
already heard all this. But New Year's
2023, I had to surrender. I told God,
"I'm weak. You are strong. I give you
permission. Take this out of my life. I
don't want it anymore." Because God will
not take things out of your life that
you are cherishing. He's not a thief.
He's knocking on the door of your heart.
He's not bashing in doors. That's what
Satan does. He uses force, coercion,
tricks, deceit, all that stuff. Jesus is
knocking on the door of your heart. He's
telling you, "This is my will for your
life. Will you allow it in your life?
will you allow me to come in and clean
up? Or are we just going to let Jesus in
the front door but not in the the back
room? Don't go in this room. You can go
in any of the house but not this room.
And so if we're cherishing any sin at
all, he's he's not going to forcefully
take it out of your life. So I reached
that point of surrender. I woke up the
next day without a single withdrawal. It
was supernatural. Supernatural freedom.
And from that point on, I still had
temptation because Satan is the tempter.
He's all around. So for two years
straight, I was tempted every single day
to get a beer. And at that point, I had
to pray, "God, give me the strength not
to go in there and buy a beer." But he
got me through the hardest part, which
was the withdrawals. And now when people
reach out to me and say, "I want what
you have. How'd you get it?" I was one
of those people, unfortunately, that
Aubrey's saying that I was like, "Just
surrender." Because that worked for me.
But it's not that doesn't work for a lot
of us. Yeah. It didn't happen that way
for me. I had to fight a good fight. Oh,
hard. My dad is in the chat. He just
said 2013. I don't know what I said, but
New Year's
2013 is when I surrendered. Um, but
yeah, like I'm saying, I'm not against
12step programs in a sense. Oh, I want
to be so careful with that because man,
those programs, they they tell you to
believe in a higher power. It doesn't
matter what. You can believe in that
doororknob if you want
to. Maybe some of the Christian
recovery. I don't know. I don't I don't
want to say anything. Yeah, we're not
going to get into that tonight, but we
might, can we say we might be having a
different show that covers that. We are
going to We have a guest that's going to
talk about all that. If you've went
through a 12step program and you're
free, thank God. The problem with those
programs are they don't let you be free.
A lot of them. They come back your whole
life. There's people that come in there
be like, I'm a I'm a 10 years struggling
addict. No, you're not. 10 years
alcoholic. Uh they say I'm I'm 10 years
alcoholic recovering. No, you're free,
brother. 10 years. You're free. What?
Stop carrying that title. You're not an
addict. Yeah. Christ has come to set you
free. And he who is free is free indeed.
So don't don't claim that stuff. So
we'll start with some of the the
practical things. What is God's? I don't
know why this is saying muted. Are you
guys hearing me right now? I hope
so. I'm not going to move on till I
hear if you guys can hear me. Can you
hear Can you hear my voice while this
image is on the screen? I'm not going to
move on till I hear from you
guys because it's saying I'm muted for
some reason.
Uh they just talk saying
uh are you hearing me? I
mean anybody loud and clear. Okay. Okay.
Perfect. Okay. So God's three-step plan
is found in James. James chapter 4
7-8. So God's three-step process to
victory over sin. This is amazing. It
says, "Submit yourselves therefore to
God. Resist the devil and he will flee
from you. Draw nigh to God and he will
draw nigh to you. That's James chapter 4
7 through8. So these are three steps.
What does it say? Submit yourself to
God. That's step one. Resist the devil.
That's step two. And draw near to God.
Now to get into for some of us because I
know there's going to be some
people the part about submitting is
actually linked with repentance. You
have to repent in that same step just so
we don't get hung up on semantics and
admittance. You have to admit you have a
problem. Some people that's what they
say in rehab too is like the first step
is admittance. That's true. If you
trying to tell somebody, hey man, you
got an addiction to that game or
whatever and people are like, "No, if
you're in denial, you're never going to
overcome." Right? So, I just want to
clarify that it's correct. Like the
Bible has such clear instruction right
there.
It's basically submit, repent, resist
the devil, and then draw near to God,
and he will
basically bring you close to him to
overcome.
Exactly. So, we're going to go through
these steps one by one here. Um, submit.
Step one is submit to God. So, Romans
12:1 says, "Present your bodies a living
sacrifice, holy, acceptable unto God,
which is your reasonable service." So
step one is surrendering. Step one is
admitting you have a problem and telling
God, I'm surrendering my life to you.
I'm surrendering this thing in my life
to you. I don't want it anymore. Please
take it from me. Right? For me,
um maybe I'll just tell my story real
quick so that it will fit into the
context of what we're going to be
talking about.
So for me, I was um I was raised in a
Christian home, a very good Christian
home. I was homeschooled and everything.
Um well, Dulan ruled in public school
and homeschooled for quite a while, but
I was in a in a home where we only got
to watch, as you might have seen our
sitcom uh covered episode. I was raised
on lots of Little House in the Prairie
and Bonanza and the classics. um Andy
Griffith show so and so on. So it was
very clean for the most part until I got
older and I realized they weren't but um
they're pretty pretty innocent, pretty
pure compared to a lot of things. But
then when I went off to college um first
of all I'd always been a bookworm, a
very good academic nerd and um and a
Star Wars nerd. Yeah, Star Wars, Star
Trek. Yeah, you name it. um action
movies are my thing so or were I should
say I don't do that anymore anyway but
so that's my background and then um I
just decided in college so music has
always had a part in my life I was
always feeling a beat when music was
played whether it was just a nice flowy
kind of ballerina thing I was always
dancing my mom said I was dancing in the
womb because she could feel me moving
around the whole
And then when I got out, it was true.
When there was music playing, I I was
doing some of that ballerina moves and
stuff just naturally or just kind of
boopping. And there's tons of family
films that have me like that.
And
so I was not realizing that somehow
uh as time went on and I grew
up, hip-hop music and rap music began to
have such a draw for me. That was the
music that really made me feel good when
I got into it and dance to it. And
that's why in college,
um, some things had led up to me
deciding that I was basically going to
be popular. I was going to see what the
world had for me because I'd always just
been the person that was keeping their
head down, focused on school, and so I
was going to experience the world. And I
was going to go ahead and get into
hip-hop dancing. So I did. This was in
my junior year of college.
at the very beginning and I started
going to parties. I'd never been to
parties in my life. Um, I didn't drink.
I never have. I didn't do drugs. I
didn't sleep around. I went to mingle
and learn how to mingle and socialize
like the coolest girl in the room and
the prettiest one and learn how to do
all that. And I did and do the dancing
and all that. So I quickly built
a, you know, reputation for being kind
of the guys liked the girl and would
approach me a lot and see me across the
room. So I was kind of, I don't know,
the it girl. Um, and I danced and I
began to
realize as people saw me dance, there
would be a clearing that would happen on
the floor. And that clearing ended up
being a thing where people would ask me
to dance on stage or other places. And
um I did just as I felt moved by the
music and most of the time it was very
much pop or hiphop or rap music in the
club as you might guess or at a party.
And
um what I did not realize is I was
starting to have this thing happen to me
where I would begin to dance or get up
on stage and most all of my recollection
of what I did went
away. I did amazing things. I was told
flips, um sexy moves, all kinds of
things. And when I got down or I'd walk
right off the stage,
uh, suddenly I was back to somewhat of
consciousness
and asked, "What did I do?" Like, "What
did I do?" Because there were men
everywhere who were starting to offer me
money, cars, their house keys, proposals
of marriage.
Um,
[Music]
and it was scary. All of a sudden, it
was like I had put myself straight in
the middle of everyone's attention and
desire. Um, and didn't I was not
prepared for it. I had to learn that
very quickly also. And it just didn't
stop. And some of my thoughts when I
when I would get so attached to the
music, I would actually wake up junior
year, I decided I was just going to be
like totally cool and totally into it.
So, I'd put on my music while I was
getting ready for the day to get ready
for college. And it was always just kind
of
like I don't know, it was building
myself up, I guess, kind of psyching
myself out and just letting it speak to
me a lot while I got ready. And that was
for a long time. I used to really pimp
up in college, so it's almost an hour to
two hours of priming up with music just
booming. Um, and I didn't really listen
to it that hard or that
long. When I say booming, it wasn't that
loud. I mean, and and
yet it was definitely taking an effect
because if I was sad, if I was feeling
like I needed to be stronger or uh even
like I guess more sexy and just capable,
I could always just put on a song that
unfortunately always had people being
put down in it. lots of cussing and
language and built you up as a
person. Um that you felt like nobody
could touch you and you were the bomb.
Like everywhere you went, you were just
it. And it shaped my attitude and it
shaped everything. But it makes you, you
know, I guess attractive to people in
the wrong way.
Um, and quite honestly, my my views of
other people when you have to have
patience with them or they they're
having causing an inconvenience for you
or whatever, my
um my temper began to get short. And
long story short, anyway, I began to
realize that I was addicted to music.
anything that happened in my
life, I had to have music
because it's how how I got through
everything. But really, it was a cover
up for always, like I said, building
myself up to be
um I don't know, impenetrable to
everything around me. And I got a high
off of it. Was what I was hap what was
happening was I would get a high off of
it and then feel like I was amazing and
then go act that way and get all of the
popularity and everything. And I still
kept my grades up the whole time, which
is really strange. But God allowed me to
do that. I actually prayed that he would
allow me to get through college and do
this at the same time. And he kept his
end of that bargain. But
um I stopped, as you might imagine, I
stopped praying a lot. I stopped doing a
lot of the things. I didn't have daily
devotions. I stopped going to church a
lot. Um I say that, but yet I was in
some ways in our family, I only lived
two hours away from my parents. And on
the weekends, they actually expected me
to be there for church. So I would drive
down. Wow. Saturday morning after
partying almost all
night. And I would show up sometimes in
my party clothes and just be in that
pew.
And sometimes that was good actually for
me. I realized
um people were accepting they were okay
and thank God they were because I was
just going to lose it on them. Actually
I was learning to lose it on them. I had
a cussing problem as well at that time.
And so I was learning I was addicted to
it. And so that's when I plugged into
this what we're talking about. And I
asked God, you know, I have no
recollection of what I'm doing on stage.
It's scary. So something must be taking
me over. And it was always when the
music would climax when you're starting
to feel like your heart is swelling with
joy and like this power and might and
just giving into that so that your body
just flowed with dance moves. And I
would realize that my jaw, like my the
most evil look sometimes, I hate to say
this, would come over my face while I
was doing that. Wow. Like there's
pictures of Beyonce. Yes. And no one
really told me that because in some ways
they're like, "Man, you're just so
fierce while you dance." And they just
would tell me it was kind of a good
thing. And don't get me wrong, some
people are very attracted to that also
in the wrong way. And
so anyway, I asked God to please remove
it from me.
And I really couldn't go a day without
using it in some way. If something, like
I said, if something was wrong, if I
just wasn't feeling confident enough or
like happy enough that day, it was
always just kind of like it's kind of
like attending some gang meeting where
they're like, "Yeah, man. You can do
this. Yeah, go get
him." Just hit him over the head or
whatever, and you're like, "Yeah, I
could do it." Well, it causes uh
adrenaline and dopamine and all that.
Yeah, but it was never good. It was
always bashing other people. Yeah. So, I
can I really relate to um Tilla if
you've seen Schools. Yeah. School for
Profits guy. We we all kind of came out
of the hip-hop rap world and Mikey too.
And um I had a crew eventually. I don't
know. I did lots of dancing, but I just
I started started shrinking away from it
in my senior year and asking God to
please set me free from it. Because I
know music will actually be a huge part
of getting our hearts to receive
messages from the music and let it
straight in without even letting our
mind filter it. In the last days, even
this would be a big big deception. Well,
even right now it is with all this uh
do what you want to do. It's all about
do what thou wilt. Even in the Disney
movies, you know, no right, no wrong, no
rules for me. I'm free. Yes, it's
already rewriting your morals and your
feelings around that. And so, I knew it
was because I was starting to cuss. I
was starting to lose it with people. Um,
all because of music. And I would
actually when I went through it anyway,
I I asked God, "Yes, I did this to
myself. I'm sorry. I got attached to
this. I repented and I asked him to get
me through it. Whatever it took, I had I
knew it was going to be hard and I
actually had withdrawals like I was a
drug addict. I would shake so bad that
um I was tempted to tie myself down to a
chair several times. And I actually did
take that time a lot to um I was doing
well in school so I would sometimes skip
classes and go home to my apartment. I
shared it with my sister, but I was
actually using her in the wrong way,
too. She had to do all the adulting
while I was doing the partying and and
taking advantage of her. And it's taking
a long time. People don't admit it
actually ruins tons of relationships
because you're taking advantage of other
people. Addiction. Yep. And you don't
keep your promises because you're so
attached to doing this one thing even
though you made lots of well-intentioned
promises that you can't keep. And
they're just asking for you to step up
and change it for once. but you don't
have the control to do so. And so I've
had to work on that relationship and
really help um ask for forgiveness there
too and work on restoring it and with my
family. But I actually would go through
the shakes like I said
and so bad and just want to turn
something on. And you're justifying in
your mind in all kinds of ways just you
deserve it. You can do it. Just do it.
Like seriously, you just want one little
hit. It won't hurt anything. But I knew
every time that I gave into it, it would
just reinforce that habit and reinforce
the exact brain
um pathway in my brain. And so I didn't
want that anymore. I just said, I want
this gone. And so I kept fighting the
battle. And you know what happened as I
would go through all of this crying or
just fighting every chemical in my brain
to actually give in.
God actually met me there, which is
really weird for me anyway at the place.
I didn't knew I didn't deserve it
because I had not I'd been neglecting
him too, putting him far away from me.
And he showed up and in that moment,
when I mean that, he actually brought
Bible verses and songs that were godly
to my mind. Wow. that built me up and
set me free in that moment to fight
against that and continue to persevere
resisting the devil in his temptations
that he brought against me just to turn
on the music. Listen to one thing. It
wasn't immediate. I had a lot of things
that I had I fell quite a few times and
gave in. But I got up and kept
fighting and eventually I I did graduate
um at the end of my senior year like
many do. But I actually was able to say
that I got the victory over that sin.
And my my family actually never knew
that I was going through this. I would
hide it really well. I locked myself in
a lot of rooms by myself while those
withdrawals happened.
And so God just saw me through all of it
every single time. And he built some
responsibility also because as he
brought songs and and um verses to my
mind while I was feeling like I was
being plagued by like satanic forces and
temptation
constantly. He built it to a point where
he wanted me. I got to a point where
instead of actually like just turn on
the music, I got verses and everything
and then an inkling was kind of brought
to me like go get your Bible actually.
Let me show you where this is so you can
see it, read it. It wasn't really saying
to claim it. I know it sounds weird, but
I didn't claim any of these things. I
just kind of read it and lived in that
moment of reading it. And so that was me
resisting and he was inputting strength
to do so. And so that's what I think is
really real. And then as he grew me from
there, which we're going to talk about
in a minute, he said, "You need to start
replacing these things."
Now that you're good enough perhaps to
stop having withdrawals out in, you
know, so you can go out in public, go to
the park, put away all the devices
because you're probably going to be, you
know, tempted there as well. Go to the
park. Go see sunsets. Enjoy flowers,
nature, animals, others company that are
healthy for you. Go on a picnic. Like
all these things that God naturally has
for us that are healthy joys and working
out and tea. I know this sounds weird,
but I love these things now. Just tea
time with God. I don't know if you guys
have ever done done that, but do. and he
brought all those things back to me to
learn how to have time with him and
actually enjoy God's pleasures versus
Satan's pleasures for you. Amen. So
that's my full story. I'm sorry. I know
that took a while, but that is my
biggest overcoming story and it did take
two years. U so music can be very hard.
That's interesting that it was two years
because that's it was two years of
everyday temptation for me before
finally I wasn't tempted to drink or
smoke for like a year and then it was
like year four that temptation raised up
again. Pretty wild. Yeah. But um so
somebody in here says it's the same for
guys with the P word yes. And that's
that's something we get a lot in our
emails and stuff, people asking about
this particular addiction because it's
so read readily available now. You know,
like I grew up in the 90s, you used to
have
to shamefully go into a bookstore and
buy a VHS and take it home and pop it in
or a magazine or whatever. Um or if
you're younger, couldn't even go into a
bookstore, you find a magazine,
abandoned abandoned house or something,
which happened to me as a kid. But now
we have these. And it's like there was a
time when only a living room had a TV
and then it was like there's a TV in
every room and then it was like there's
only a computer in the living room and
then it was every room had their
computer and now it's every person is
walking around with a computer that fits
in their pocket with access to the
internet and it's just Satan's
playground. Yeah. And I I'll be honest,
like my family, a lot of my siblings
didn't understand what was happening
with me. They just knew I was snippity
and
uptight and I was not I separated myself
from them a lot just to get through it
by myself. And um just to say
that sometimes we don't realize
sometimes that even the Christian like
someone said, "I tried the Christian
rap. I try the Christian hip-hop is the
same thing. Like it all has that beat
that starts to overtake me. Um, and so I
have to walk out of a lot of shops,
malls, stores even to this day or turn
off a lot of music or even walk away
from people who are playing music. My
siblings um like some music. It's not
even bad, don't get me wrong. They like
some of the purest Christian music,
but and they mean well, but we have come
to some kind of understanding that they
have to ask me if I'm ready to have
music on because some of their music
genres that are so Christian,
um, after about an hour or two of it
being on, it starts grading on me to the
point where I want to go back. I really
want to go back to the hiphop and rap. I
don't know what happens, but I just
really don't.
You have to know your triggers. You have
to know your boundaries. And I have to
tell them sometimes like, "Can we please
turn that off?" Yep. And you have to
respect that. Sometimes people really
need sanity, peace of mind. Um, and they
don't know this, by the way. I haven't
told them. this is why I need this to
happen for me. But they are very
uh respectful of that usually and yeah,
go ahead. Hopefully one day we'll do an
episode on music, but man, that is a a
tricky topic and we don't listen to
music very often. I don't really anymore
much man. I it was years that went by
when I when I started when God woke me
up and I started like going down the
rabbit hole a lot and researching. I
didn't have time for music in my life.
People would ask, it got to be where
people would be like, what kind of music
you listen to? And I'm like, uh, good
question. I don't know. I haven't
listened to music in like three years.
Every free moment I had, which was
usually traveling to and from work,
which was an hour drive. I was listening
to podcasts. I just want I was so
My addiction became knowledge. I'm like,
I want to know what's going on in the
world. I want to know what's the
deceptions are. I want to know what the
truth is. Yeah. And I didn't have time
to just listen to music and la and
listen to that fun music. I just stopped
listening to it. Not because I was
scared of it, not because I thought it
was a sin. I just didn't have time for
it. And maybe that was a blessing.
Because music is a a tricky topic.
There's no Bible verse that says, "Thus
sayeth the Lord, this beat ratio is a
sin or whatever." I mean, but I've
watched a 10hour presentation by
Christian Bardall called The Distraction
Dilemma. It's amazing. I agree with
pretty much all of it. Yeah. But I still
walk away and say, "Well, I'm not a I'm
not a science major or a music like
music major. I feel like if I don't know
how to read music or know frequencies
and tempos, like then I don't know
what's right or wrong." Well, and it is
hard because I went down that rabbit
hole trying to understand what was
happening inside of me because it was it
had to do with the beat. It's the kind
of rhythm that's going on. So, a lot of
Christian music has it too, and I just
can't take it. Um, so contemporary
music, Christian music does it does that
very same thing. And,
um, when we were at Little Light, um, we
did a whole episode on this guy who
writes music for all of Hollywood. Oh,
yeah. What is his name again? I can't
remember. Something. Martin. Oh, yeah.
Max Martin. Max Martin. and he actually
has this whole system that seems like
it's um automatic writing for him. He's
given the words he's
given notes it's supposed to hit on and
how quick those notes go and what you
know what I mean all that. And there is
there's a science to it because he's he
even teaches a class on it and stuff.
Don't please don't get into that. But
there is a whole science to kind of
playing Satan's game with that because
what I learned the answer that I got is
also the same as Ivor Myers. Ivrav Myers
came from the rap in hip-hop world too.
Yeah. And he learned that uh the
simplest answer is that you can see this
in voodoo. In voodoo they use syncopated
rhythms to actually get someone into a
trance and give up their soul to be
sacrificed. And usually when this the um
the one who's dancing to be prepared for
sacrifice, when the music reaches its
climax, they always end up giving this
heart like they're flailing with their
heart and their chest open to be taken.
And that is when they usually do take
the heart of that person in sacrifice.
And so I was really good at that motion
in music and I didn't know why because
it naturally came to me at those moments
when the music would build. And yet when
he went over the fact that and I
researched it as well that this is very
true in voodoo
um I freaked out because I did not know
that I'd been participating in
witchcraft.
That was when I realized I further was
this is same thing as bail worship. Bail
worship does use music to do that and
and get you to want to um have anger
towards others and do such things. And
so I had to repent deeply. I still have
a lot like I'm over it, but at the same
time I realized the depth of my sin as
well. And it hurts. Yeah. I uh I can
identify with Studio Dawn here
about really hard letting go of Tulle
and Nine Nails. Man, those were Tulle,
9inch Nails, Marilyn Manson were like my
three favorite alltime bands at that
time period. Then it it changed in a
suicide silence and stuff like that. But
music is such a personal thing. I mean
it becomes your identity. I literally
looked like Marilyn Manson. I mean it I
idolized him. It wasn't just music to
me. And I told people that. I was like
music is life. Like it's not just And I
looked like Jojo. Oh yeah. Jojo. I did.
I don't know if anybody in this group
knows who Jojo. Don't go look that up.
Just maybe you can look at what she
looks like but don't look at her music.
This has already become the music
episode, but I do want to tell you if
you guys I've seen it in in the chat,
uh, X Ministries, Ex Ministries, Craig
Lewis, he does amazing work. Check out
Christian Bardall. He's got 10hour
presentation on this thing. And there's
and Ivor Meyers testimony and also it's
called Escape from the Black Hole and
also his presentation called Sonic
Warfare. Very good. And then I've
covered it before, but
the exposing the music industry parts
one through 10 was actually very helpful
to me to realize what was happening to
me as well. Yeah, that's very good. Um,
that's kind of hard a little bit harder
to find on YouTube. You have to piece
together all the parts. You got to go to
Rumble or Boot, you'll find it there.
And so, sorry, but we have had other
addictions. I also
um the first thing I was ever addicted
to was video games as a youth. Um it
very it was very short-lived, thank God,
because I realized it was also making me
snippity with my family very quickly and
I gave it up. I actually looked at it
and went, "You're doing this to me.
You're brainwashing me and you're making
me not act like myself." I am so
impressed with her and her siblings over
the years. like she's told me things
that happened in their childhood and
everything and how in their childhood
had convictions and set them down and
walked away from them. I'm just like I
as a childhood for me I just wanted to
indulge in everything like I'm going to
watch all Nickelodeon. I'm going to
watch MTV video games. I didn't feel
like how how could it be bad? It's just
entertainment. I couldn't see it. I
actually saw which sounds weird. It was
an Xbox. I would look at the Xbox and
don't of course it didn't have eyes. It
doesn't have a face, but I would
actually sense and and kind of look at
it as though and realize that the demon
was getting to me in there through it to
make me act that way. And I was addicted
to just playing it and just going in
being in the moment of it. And this was
a racing game, you guys. Like I didn't
like play anything that was
very bad at all. Not Grand Theft Auto.
No, this is
uh Need for Speed.
Yeah. And I I I can hear the music and
everything. That is some people's
addiction. Some people their addiction
is racing. And so I uh had to give it
up. I did. I walked away from that
thing. I put this the remote or the
controller down and I just had an
episode with my mom where I lost it on
her and she said, "I don't know what's
happening to you, but you are not
yourself." And I looked at that Xbox and
I said, "Actually, that's true. I would
never I would have respect for my mom
and I would not talk back like that."
Wow. And I put it down and I did not go
back again. I saw that device as cursed
never to touch it cuz it was the devil.
It was basically like something not to
touch. Don't get me wrong, I'm not
looking at Xboxes completely that way.
You can play some games, but I've even
had just so you know, I'm human. even
the some of the ways that are most pure.
The last addiction I had was while I was
pursuing my masters before needing
Mikey and um getting married to him and
I was going through my master's degree
and I was struggling with the royal
kingdom app, the game on your phone and
it's like I don't know what that is. Is
it a puzzle game? It's a puzzle game and
all these jewels, all the stuff that
mimics bejeweled and all this and I
there's like 200 levels and I was making
my way and I just got addicted to
accomplishing the levels and I had to
actually tell myself, you know what,
you're almost missing time to do your
homework, getting ready for the day. I
had to go to the DMV also and I like sat
there and they called my number even.
Wow. and I wanted to just play. And so I
almost missed my appointment that I'd
sat there for. I just thought, "This is
ridiculous. You're not doing this very
well. Grow up." And so I did. I was
like, "Delete." Wow. And I just thought,
I don't care. This is not good. And so
from the
hardest addictions, like for me, music,
and I have dealt with some of the lust.
Um, women can have it too. That was also
in my college years.
to and that's all chemicals. So that was
like some of the hardest things I could
ever have done when you're fighting your
your inner working of your chemicals in
your brain and all the emotions that it
starts making you feel that are not your
own. Yeah. To the most simple of a game.
And I do want to put together a
presentation about dopamine because all
addictions are based on dopamine. That's
why when you see these people, and I I
hate to sound like I'm talking bad about
them, but people who are in Alcoholics
Anonymous or Narcotics Anonymous, you
see them and they are in groups standing
outside chain smoking, drinking
caffeinated
coffee and eating sugar cookies. I mean,
they literally traded their addiction to
alcohol for smoking and cookies and
caffeine. It's still an addiction. is
still causing a dopamine thing. And
um that that's all it is. Every
addiction is based on dopamine. And I I
call those secondary addictions because
most people don't realize that they're
doing that. Um a lot of people who
transition from alcohol will go to soda
and keep that addiction in their life
forever. Yeah. Or um carbonated things a
lot too. But you get the point. Like you
can just start picking up a different
addiction instead and that's not okay.
Yeah. So, there there will be in the
future a video hopefully on music.
Definitely one on dopamine
because that's what everything's giving
me. When you watch a movie, when you're
playing a video game and you're getting
all those points and leveling up, it's
all dopamine. But while we're on that
topic, just real quick, like I said,
God's pleasures of enjoying an animal
while they're you're petting them on
your lap and watching the sunrise,
gardening, doing certain hobbies that
God meant you to have like cooking or
true companionship and relationship. And
so there's all these
things. When you have his pleasures in
your life, it gives you a dopamine rush
too, the right way. Exactly. And it
starts taking over that wiring of your
brain. It's actually resetting you back
to his design. And so I started doing
that. Yeah. I just let go of Satan's
pleasures and filled it with God's
everything Satan has is a counterfeit.
So dopamine is not bad. It depends on
what you're using that dopamine for. God
made dopamine so that when you're
witnessing to somebody and you're
sharing the truth with them in
scriptures or whatever and they're
getting that, oh yeah, I get it. The aha
moment and you're get and you get
excited like, yeah, you're getting it.
Or yeah, if you're a door knocker,
you're one of those people that knock on
people's doors and you get rejected and
rejected and finally somebody's like,
"I've been praying for somebody to come
give Bible studies with me. Come in."
And you're like, "Yeah." And like angels
rejoice over one repentance center,
right? That excitement, that joy, that
is dopamine. And you want to do it
again. Like I want to knock on the next
door. Like I want to witness to the next
person. But it doesn't come overnight.
No. That's the thing. You go from being
that addicted person to actually having
to work at your relationship with God a
lot. You're like, "I don't want to do
this. I actually don't want to be
praying to you right now. I don't even
want to have worship with you, but I'm
going to do it anyway." Because that's
the you fighting the chemical depression
and the kind of
hopelessness and substituting it right
then and there because you choose him
over that other thing. And these are
parts of the steps that we're going to
go through right now. Okay. So, step one
is submit to God. We went over that. So,
what does that look practically
submitting? You know, you're
surrendering. You're admitting that I
have a problem and I can't I can't
overcome it because if we're real
ourselves, we can do nothing of
ourselves. Addiction is addiction. It's
very hard. If if you have a very very
very strong willpower, sometimes you can
overcome it, but most of the time you
can't do it without God. And so, what
does this look like
practically? Begin your day with
surrender. Verbally say, "God, I give
you my mind, my choices, my desires
today." This comes from Romans 12:1.
Keep confessing. Keep admitting that I
am weak, but you are strong. Putting
your faith in God, setting boundaries.
Set boundaries for weak areas before
temptation arises. That's what we're
talking about. Know your triggers. Yep.
If you know that going into that gas
station is going to tempt you to buy a
beer, that was my thing. Avoid that gas
station or whatever. Don't go in. Pay at
the pump, you know, whatever it is. um
fast from things that strengthen the
flesh, social media, secular music, junk
food to weaken the carnal nature. So,
it's just like anything, the more you
feed it, there's a a parable basically
of uh the weak dog and the strong dog.
Whatever dog you feed the most is going
to win that dog fight. So set boundaries
and fast from things that are causing
you to stumble. Fast from social media,
secular music, junk food, whatever is
feeding that carnal mind and obey
immediately. Whatever your convictions
is telling you. Don't debate the
conviction. Yield instantly when God
shows you something is wrong. Yep. So a
lot of times people say, you know, is is
this thing wrong? is that when in doubt,
throw it out. I I I think it's rare that
you're going to say something good. It's
rare that you're going to question if
something really good is wrong or not.
It's rare you'll be like, "Is reading
the Bible bad or is eating fruit bad?"
or whatever it is. Most of the time it
it's not. But if you have any kind of
doubt, that's a red flag. You know, if
people say like, "Is masturbation a
sin?" Well, why are you questioning it?
Why why do you even have a a doubt, you
know, a red flag about it? I just want
to break into this real quick. We're
having some issues, it looks like, with
uh Patreon. Someone said it's only set
up for free membership. That's why we
haven't promoted it yet. Okay. Uh sorry
about that. We weren't aware that it was
not. We'll work on that tomorrow morning
probably, but someone asked for a PayPal
link instead. So, we do have execute
brand. Execute used to be my clothing
line. So, that's my email.
executebrand@gmail.com is how you can
support us through Patreon. Thank you so
much
for your generous giving. We really
appreciate that because we can't do this
without you. This is really we walked
away from our jobs to do what God called
us to do and it was a a scary thing, but
God has provided from day one and we're
just trusting him every month. So, um so
let's get back to this then. I I have a
comment on that real quick because
again, it didn't start that way. I
didn't even think actually to ask God
into my mind, my choices, and my desires
like your first suggestion says there.
Oh, yeah. For practical application. No,
when I was going through it, I didn't at
all. You grow in your faith with God.
Yeah. And honestly, you're just fighting
a battle to begin with
um to
start. And then he gets you to a point
where now I know to use this kind of
verbal claiming in God's name to have my
mind protected, my choices, and my
desires be his every day. But that took
I don't know
like a long time to become a mature
Christian in that and know how to use
prayer in that way. So just so you know
it it just doesn't come overnight like
that. Oh yeah. But it is step one of
James here is surrender. Yep. What was
it? Submit yourselves to God. Resist the
devil who flee from you and draw near to
God. Yeah. So when I when I have step
one being begin your day with surrender,
that means admitting that you have a
problem, that you are weak, but you
know, and you're putting your faith in
him that he can give you the victory
because that's where it is. You're not
going to do it on your own. He gives you
the victory. So step two is resist the
devil. What does that look like? Well,
first Peter 5 8-9 says, "Be sober. Be
vigilant because your adversary, the
devil, walks about like a roaring lion,
seeking whom he may devour. Resist him
steadfast in the faith.
Resisting the devil requires both
discernment and defiance. You must
identify lies and temptations. This is
identifying the sin, identifying your
triggers, then fight back, not in your
own strength, but with the word of God
as Jesus did in the wilderness. We talk
about this all the time. How did Jesus
fight Satan in the wilderness? It is
written. It is written. It is written.
It is a personal pet peeve of mine when
Christians are like, "Oh, Satan, he
ain't nothing. He's this little thing."
Satan is a beautiful angel of light.
He's a one angel in the Bible could slay
thousands of people. He He's your
biggest enemy. He's dangerous. He
deceived Eve, a perfect being in a
perfect world. Like, we are deceiving
ourselves if we think Satan ain't
nothing. He's this little thing and the
and we have nothing to fight him with
except the word of God. Prayer and
quoting scripture. It's the sword of the
spirit. That's why it's called the sword
of the spirit because it's our offensive
weapon. Defensive. Offensive. I don't
know the difference on defensive.
Defensive. It's how we fight. We can't.
Jesus didn't try to outsmart him. He
didn't try to fight him physically. He
just said, "Look, this is what the word
of God says." Boom, boom, boom. It's
like legal. It's legal law. It is. But I
thought I was going to die. Quite
honestly, I thought I was going to die
so much. And if I told God, even if I do
die through this, getting through
withdrawal from this, I'll do it. I will
be clean by throw us in the fire. We
will not bow to the image and I will be
yours. Amen. You have to reach that rock
bottom place like God, no matter what it
takes, I'm Yeah. I'm going to do it for
you.
Yeah. And so when I went through that
and I had to surrender like that, it was
intense, you guys. Like it is who's I
had to hold on. And I know this sounds
really weird, but I had to actually grip
the
couch so hard while I was sitting there
just to occupy my hands to not do
anything, turn on anything or even I
don't know just g grip my my own arms
and like hurt them or whatever because
it does it comes to a point where it's
like you could get out of this, you
know, like you he's playing with you so
hard. Satan is you have bad thoughts
about yourself.
He wants you to take yourself out if he
can get you to that point. Um, all this
stuff. So, it it's really terrible and
just keep fighting because if you after
hours of fighting, I would just have
muscles that were aching so much. But I
got through it and it would stop and I'd
have peace.
Amen. So, so next
step, well, first it's resist the devil.
What does this look like practically?
How do you resist the devil? I mean, we
talked about fighting in with scripture.
Yeah. But there's also some other
practical things here. Um Jesus said,
"If your hand offends you, cut it off."
That's I hope you know that that's not
literal. That you're not going to cut
your hand off. Right? He's saying,
"Look, know your triggers." That's what
if he was in 2025, that's what he would
have said. Know your triggers. If a
device, location, or relationship makes
sin easier, remove it without
hesitation. Sometimes your best friends,
your family can be your trigger. When I
stopped drugs, pe my friends stopped
coming around. Uh they would pass weed
my way and I just say, "No, man. I'm
good. You go for it." And those friends
stopped coming around. And I heard a
quote that said, "I prayed for God to
remove my enemies and I started losing
friends." Yes. And I was like, whoa,
that's what I'm dealing with right now.
I thought these people were my friends.
You start seeing the demons manifest
that they are, not to say they're these
people are demons, but they're being
used by demons to infiltrate you. Yeah.
Um, if you're struggling with TV, unplug
it, put it in the closet, get rid of
that thing. If that's your temptation,
then remove it. You We have to do
something
practical and physical to help us
overcome this thing. We're first we're
admitting, we're surrendering, and
telling God, "I can't do it on my own."
Now, we're going to do a practical tip,
and we're going to remove that
temptation physically. If you're tempted
by alcohol, replace it immediately with
water or tea. Flood your body with some
with a better option. That's we're
actually going to talk about that more
coming up. Social media, is it feeding
your lust? Delete the app. Just get rid
of it. Fast from it. Um, use scripture.
Me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me memorize key verses for your
struggle. An example is I made a
covenant with my eyes. Job says if
you're having lustful thoughts than your
eyes, I I made a covenant with my eyes.
Claim that promise. Memorize that
promise and pray aloud when tempted.
Speak life, not defeat. There is a such
thing, you know, this whole thing. We
did a video on
um law of
attraction. It's so close to the truth.
That's why people got suck get sucked
into it. There is power in your words.
The Bible says there's power in the in
the tongue. There's p power of life and
death in the tongue. Do
not speak defeat. Don't say um you know
I just can't overcome or whatever. You
can admit you're weak. Admit he's
strong. You can say and be truthful
yourself though I messed up again. Yeah,
I would definitely do that. But God,
please help me. But the Bible says, "A
righteous man falls seven times and gets
back up." Don't stay down and wallow in
your sin because you fell. A righteous
man gets back up every time, no matter
how many times you fall. Yep. So, this
is a radical amputating of the stumbling
blocks that Jesus was referring to.
Yeah. Cut off your hand. That
means delete that app. put a device on
your phone that's gonna keep you from
looking at something you're not supposed
to look at. Whatever you got to do and
intentionally lose that password. But
now, yeah, but now there is a void in
your life. When you get rid of these
very pleasurable, dopamine inducing
things in your
life, it's going to be a struggle. You
can white knuckle it and get rid of that
thing and a week later you fell back.
you you will be bragging I ain't done it
in a week and then all of a sudden you
fall for it again. Then you're beating
yourself up. You're you're saying I keep
falling into this thing saying you have
to fill that void. You have a void
there. It's it's a legitimate thing.
There's nothing wrong with it. You had
something there that was feeding you and
now you have to fill that thing with
something positive. Like we said,
dopamine is not necessarily the bad
thing. It it was created by God. Yeah.
You have to fill it with something good.
So when you are tempted to watch that
thing you're not supposed to watch, make
yourself do 50 push-ups if that's
something. These are just ideas. You
pick your own choice. Take a walk. I
want to talk about that too because I
didn't have anybody to confide in and it
was okay. God was my person because when
I did have people like let's just say I
made this mistake a few times because I
needed help but I tried to ask
somebody not really I wanted them just
to be there to listen and be there for
me but instead they kind of looked at me
like I was crazy and I don't know if
you've had that but unfortunately a lot
of God's people in the church do that
instead and it's just judgmental and
they go I don't understand and So, um,
just like Job, his friends were the
worst people to be around. Um, I had to
learn just to be,
um, ready for people not to understand
my struggles because we're all
different.
And then when I went and dealt with it
by
myself, I still like have people who
don't quite understand it, but I got
through it. And so, I I don't know. I
just want to encourage you that just
because others don't understand it
doesn't mean you're just crazy and
you're like
completely desperate. You don't need to
be desperate for other people. You need
to be desperate for
God and not follow after them. We have
examples all through the Bible where
people were alone. Um Elijah was alone.
Everyone was worshiping Baal. He was
literally the only one. They're like,
"You have a fake god." And he's like,
"Yeah, okay. We'll see who can bring
fire down from heaven." He was alone.
Shadrach, Meek, and Abedneo alone. Every
the whole world was bowing to the image
and they were willing to go into the
fire. We're alone. So, it is good to
have friends, accountability partners,
prayer partners, give you good counsel.
Do not commiserate. I have learned that
also because soon you're just like the
AA meetings or whatever where they were
all in it. So, they're justifying,
"Yeah, man, I did it, too. I just fell
again. It's fine. We'll we'll we'll
overcome this one day." Like, it's
always a one day type of thing, but it
doesn't really happen much. Usually, it
doesn't happen for those people a lot.
No. And so I would just say if you have
someone that you can talk
to, don't try to commiserate with them
in in a sin that you both have because
it's going to be
very suck you in and get you stuck in a
pit. Also, one thing I did learn from
someone who went through NA was don't
romanticize about it. When you have that
void and you're thinking back, man,
right now I wish I could
just have some meth or alcohol or weed
or whatever. Don't think about, man, I
love the way it smelled, the way it made
me feel. Think about the relationships
it destroyed, the pock marks it put on
your face, the the prison that you had
to spend for it. Think about all the bad
things. Associate negative with that
sin. Don't That's right. think about the
good things that the quote unquote good
things because they're never really
good. We all like our sins.
Unfortunately, we all like the things we
fell into. We We know the exact feeling.
We could even still replay them in our
minds if we really want to go back, but
we shouldn't. Like he's saying, "Yeah,
let it go. That is your past. It It
doesn't live anymore." Amen. That's why
we're supposed to die to the old man.
So, here here's just some ideas, you
know? Yeah. Do 15 push-ups every time
you're tempted. Take a walk. enjoy God's
nature, get fresh air, sunshine, all
these things are are actually beneficial
to help you overcome addictions in your
life. Uh, call a godly friend. If you
have someone that you know, like this
person's on the straight and narrow.
Every time I'm around them, they're
always talking about God. They have
great counsel, call that friend um just
for encouragement, for scripture, for
prayer. And journal, journal your
battles and your victories. Uh, I was
never a journaler until
a lot of hard things hit me and I began
to write my prayers out even because I
got to where I didn't even know what to
pray or or every time I try to pray I'd
fall asleep or whatever and I was just
like I'm not gonna I'm going to write
this prayer out so I know that my prayer
is out and uh remember temptation is not
a sin but lingering with it is dangerous
for giving Okay. Yeah. So Jesus was
tempted in the wilderness. He never
sinned. Temptation is not a sin. There's
a a saying that says you can't stop
birds from flying over your head, but
you can stop them from building a nest
in your hair. So temptation comes along,
you see a beautiful woman, look the
other way. You, you know, you don't
stare and undress her with your eyes.
That's that becomes the that becomes the
sin of adultery. Jesus said to look upon
a woman to lust after her is the same as
committing adultery. But the temptation
like oh there's a woman there. Okay,
that's a temptation. Now what are you
going to do? Are you going to give into
that temptation or are you going to turn
the other way? No, you learn to look
away. Even when I had to give up cussing
those same two years when they became a
part of my life for the first time and
then I had to get rid of them. It was
hard and I had to just like many people
have steps like I started
having just trying to control my mouth
from saying it first when your mind is
still doing it. You know you're still
sinning against God but you're working
on it and then you're getting your mind
not to say that because you start
actually in your mind using words that
are normal like that really bothers me
instead
of all of those explicit words. Um, and
learning how to be like, I can't control
that about someone even though I don't
like it, but that's in God's hands now.
Like, you start talking yourself in more
mature, realistic ways with vocabulary
that is more educated also. And so, I
did have veggie words for a while like
other people. Um, that doesn't help
though. After a while, you realize you
again are picking up a secondary
addiction. You're you're substituting
things and that's just not helpful.
Yeah, I didn't know what um it meant for
a while until recently when it says,
well, not recently, years ago. But when
the Bible says, "Let your yes be yes and
your no be no." That means our
character, our life should play out
where everyone knows if you said it, you
mean it. It's truthful. That person
never lies. Like if you ask them a
question and they tell you something,
they're if they're saying if they're
giving you an answer, it's true. And so
we should never have to say, "I swear on
my mama's grave." like or I swear to God
that this is true. You don't have to
swear. You don't have to say anything.
You don't have to say a cuss word. Yeah.
Like H. Yeah. Or F. Yeah. Just Yes.
Yeah. Let your yes be yes. Your no be
no. We don't have to
make it more elaborate than that.
Exactly. You have a reputation then
after you built that character with
someone that they go, Mikey's not like
that. No, he doesn't speak like that. He
doesn't do that. He has a reputation of
gold. like solid what he says is what he
says, right? And what he does, that's
what we want to have. That's right. So,
and I'm seeing people in here with real
struggles. People are saying, "Look, I
pray every day. I'm still falling into
it."
We're we're we're trying to give you the
best that we can from scripture. What's
helped us and we're not perfect. We
still struggle. And this is this is a
daily thing. Pick up your cross daily.
You do overcome it eventually, though. I
will say I do not Oh yeah, the
temptation is still there, but I do not
have any of these addictions that I
spoke of anymore. Yeah. Um I used to be
in love with marijuana, in love with
alcohol. Like if you look at my old
pictures on my profile, you see me just
Oh, I just love it. Every picture me
smoking a blunt, pouring beer into my
mouth, like I glamorized it. And now it
disgusts me. When I see other people
doing those things, I'm like, you are
ruining your life. You're you're a
slave. I hate it. But I will say that we
have to be honest with ourselves. A lot
of us are not. We look at people who are
have earbuds and their phone out a lot
and they're just jamming to stuff the
whole day and they look really cool.
They look usually like they're really
popular and stuff, too. And life is
really easy for them. And, you know,
they're watching a video or playing a
game with any free time they have.
They're totally plugged in to Satan's
like brain waves like just having
electrodes on your brain as though he's
just directly Satan's brainwash
playground. Yeah. And don't envy them. I
learned that really quick. But what I
will say in monitoring yourself is
knowing that if you struggle at all with
any kind of YouTube or internet or
whatever, I had to learn because I did.
I I looked at music videos. I would have
a song that came up inside of me that I
wanted to listen to. I'm like, "Ah, just
one maybe." And you get on YouTube, you
look up that one music video, and you
know that that feed is going to feed you
more. And you go, I no, I'll just listen
to one. I can I can fight this. I can be
responsible. Don't ever, and I'm going
to say this, don't ever just try to be
responsible. Just fight it. Just get
away from it. Resist completely. Because
many of us, whether it is that or
whatever,
we end up watching other videos. We're
going to be honest. We have to be honest
with ourselves. Like, we actually do not
have the self-control just to watch what
we should be watching and then get off.
Oh, you're like, "Wait, what was that
sermon? Oh, cool. I'm going to look it
up. YouTube.com." And there's 20
thumbnails all with that are
strategically made for you to click on.
Yeah. And you're like, "Oh, what was I
here for again?" Right. So somebody
asked um what about So what about the
same logic for the internet? That's
where I had to deal with the internet
still. I was in college. I had to write
papers. I had to research tons of
things. I had to be and this is what
they God wants us to do. I had to
actually set aside rules for myself. You
get on that computer, you research only
and only the things you need to. You
write your paper and you get off.
And I had to keep that promise to God
and I did. And that's why the first
slide talked about boundaries.
And I don't know how you could I don't
know make it where only certain pages
work or something. But you can't
actually say that. You have to have to
have a discipline. That's the truth of
it. Yeah. So these are things you got to
replace that void with something
positive. And a personal thing for me,
my brain was programmed every time I'm
thirsty, I want a beer because I drank
beer all day long except when I was at
work. And so when I was thirsty, ooh, I
just want to crack that cold, fizzy
beer. Everything about it, I love the
taste of it, the way it made me feel,
all that. And so when I
was beer free, because God set me free,
my brain was still programmed, man, I'm
thirsty. I want a beer. And I'm like,
nope, you know what? I'm gonna drink a
gallon of water. I'm gonna fill my body
up so much that I can't fit a beer in
me. And I would literally drink so much.
I I I be it became my trademark. People
knew me. I was walking around with a
gallon of water everywhere I went. Big
jug. Everywhere I went, they saw me with
that big jug of water. But I would chug
it until it was like water was up to
here. I mean, if I bent over to pick up
something, I'd throw up in my mouth. It
was that full. M but I had no room for
beer. And that's what I had to do. It
was healthy. I was hydrated and and I
didn't have beer in me. And that was the
a practical step that I I had to do. So
that's what we're trying to tell you
here. Replace that void with something
positive because you do have a void. So
step number three, the last step is draw
near to God.
The word of God is living and active,
discerning the thoughts of the
intentions of the heart. Um, God's word,
when you read it, it convicts you. It
makes you have a a desire to be closer
to God. It's how you communicate with
God. How do you pray to God, but you
don't really hear much back from God?
Read his word. That's why it's called
his word. He speaks to us through it.
Um, you will seek me and find me when
you search for me with all your heart.
So, how are we going to find God? How
are we going to have a loving
relationship with him? It's on our part.
He's He's always there. He's with arms
wide open like the prodical son. We've
walked out into the darkness. He's
waiting for us to come to him. So, when
we draw near to him, that's when he
comes into your life. When he knows that
you genuinely want a relationship with
him, you genuinely genuinely want to
give him the um the authority to come
into your life and clean up. Mhm. He
will do it. But you have to be genuine.
You have to say, "I am done with this
stuff. I want nothing but you, God."
After submission and resistance, there's
a void left behind. It must be filled or
sin will return with reinforcements.
This is true. This is talking about when
uh these demons were cast out of or a
demon was cast out of this person and it
said that the demon saw that the vessel
was empty and came back with seven more
friends. So do not leave your vessel
empty. That's the problem with
meditation and all this stuff. Empty
your mind and all this stuff. You're
supposed to fill your mind. Yeah. With
God's word. I'm just going to add to
that when it says you you will seek me
and find me. I'll go back to the other
one. You will seek me and find me when
you search for me with all your heart.
You guys, I was in a state just like a
lot of you are just in a very depressed
addicted state. I will be honest. Um
found it hard to function a lot of the
time, get out of bed, but I had to.
And what you see now um with all the
stuff that I speak on that's very I
think deep and enlightening that is me
taking that promise to God and I asked
him for answers on all of these things.
That's how I know these things now. And
he kept his end of the bargain that if I
asked and I
I was seeking for answers he would give
them to me. And that is true with many
things. I I'm a functional nutritionist
and I get answers for how to treat
people from God. He does show me things.
My research has become quite a blessing
because with spiritual things, he helps
me with that too. So just to learn that
it it doesn't naturally come again to
you. You have to work on a relationship
with God and learning how to use these
promises and things.
But he is true to it and it does work
and that is proof. I'm I'm proof of
that. I would never have been speaking
about these things before. Amen. Um, by
the way, if you've been blessed by this
so far, give this video a thumbs up.
Really helps get this video out into the
algorithm. So many people need to know
these practical tips. How does the How
do I make the Bible real to me? How do I
have victory over over sin in my life?
And for us, this is what we found works.
And so, um, we're going to keep going
with this because practical applications
of drawing near to God and he'll draw
near to you. Schedule time with God. If
you have to, if you're one of those
calendar schedule people, schedule time
with God. Make an appointment early in
the morning or in the evening. These are
times that you're not filled with uh
your job, school,
uh errands. You know, places close at
night and places aren't open in the
morning. So, if you have to get up 30
minutes earlier, that doesn't sound like
a lot, right? If you usually wake up at
7, wake up at 6:30, that doesn't sound
like too much of a difference, right?
Spend 30 minutes with God a day. It'll
do wonders in your life. Yep. Pray and
read.
uh start a prayer habit. Use Psalm 51 or
119 to to guide your words. The the
Psalms are literally songs to God. Like
we we sing praise and worship songs,
right? Even better, sing biblical
scripture and it's right there in the
Psalms and read scripture that
transforms. Romans 6 through8, death to
death to sin, life and spirit. Galatians
5, the fruit of God's
law, Psalm 119, love for God's law.
Because when you fully surrender to
Christ, you will become a new creature.
I'm not the same person I was. I look at
those pictures of me in the past, that's
not the same person. Not at all. I don't
have the same desires. I don't have the
same ambitions. I don't have the same
dreams. It's a completely different
person. And that's not because of
anything I did. It's because the closer
I got to God, the more he transformed my
life. He can't do that if you don't get
close to him. The the closer It's just
like when you have a best friend or a
spouse, you guys start acting alike,
right? You become like that person. We
need to do that with God. The closer we
get with God, the more of his character
we will receive. Listen to
scripture-based sermons or podcasts
daily. Limit worldly voices. Don't Don't
be listening to Joe Rogan and the news
and all this garbage. Let's listen to
things that are uplifting and preferably
godly scriptures, sermons, things like
that. Um, candid truth, you know, things
like that.
The more time you spend with his word
and presence, the less attractive sin
becomes. And that's so true. Like I was
talking about like when I see alcohol
now, I see people drinking it. Back in
the day, I would have been like, "Whoa,
I gotta have a beer, too." Now, I'm just
like, "That's disgusting. I can't
believe I was in that trap. I can't
believe this person is in that trap. I I
hate it." And that only came because of
God. I was in love with that stuff.
So, God's seal. Um, there is a video on
this channel if you go under the video
section, not the live section, and
scroll and look for a video that's
called sealed for your protection. It
talks about what is the seal of God.
Because we talk about the mark of the
beast a lot, not we, but Christians in
general talk about the mark of the
beast. We don't talk about what the seal
of God is. The seal of God is having his
name in your forehead, having his
character in your mind. Name is
synonymous with character.
when God would often change people's
names, right? Jacob, he changed his name
to Israel. The reason he changed his
name was because his character changed.
He was no longer the liar, the suppler.
Now he was Israel, whatever that means,
God. He was it was a godly name.
Um, so when it talks about having the
name of God in our foreheads, this is a
spiritual application talking about
having God's character, being like
Christ. So victory isn't about perfect
behavior. It's about a transformed
character. Look, we're not talking about
trying in your own strength to be
perfect. It's never going to happen
ever. But God can literally transform
you. And when you have his character,
when the Holy Spirit is dwelling in you
and you ask God, fill me with your Holy
Spirit to give me victory
today, then he will do that. He will
answer that prayer. A renewed mind. So
he's going to give you a transformed
character and a renewed mind. My mind's
not the same as it used to be. This is
the seal of God, having that character
of God on your forehead. And that's what
we all need in the last days. The only
way to overcome the mark of the beast is
to be sealed. And the seal of God is to
have his character, which means walking
according to God's will and not your
own. It happens step by step with every
moment of submission. Resist and
communion with the Lord. Uh submission,
resistance, resist those things that are
a problem and communion with the Lord.
These are the steps that you have to
take.
So, this is our call to action. Submit
to God daily. Schedule that time. Wake
up 30 minutes early. Spend time with
God.
Um, journal something that's going to
get you connected with God in prayer and
reading his word and surrender yourself.
Will recognize that you have a problem
that you can't you you know, you've
already you've already failed many, many
times. A righteous man falls seven times
and gets back up. You've fallen so many
times that you know you cannot do it.
Admit that you are
weak and and realize and claim that God
is strong and he can give you the
victory and surrender your will. Say,
"God, I do not want this anymore. Take
this from me. I surrender." Wave that
white flag. Resist sin and temptation by
removing stumbling blocks. Know your
triggers and get those things away from
you. They might be your friends. In a
very severe case, it might even be the
city you live in. I know addicts who
have had to move, maybe temporarily, but
they had to go because they knew that
that drug spot was just too easy to get
to. So, they moved somewhere where they
didn't know any of the drug dealers or
whatever. And draw near to God in prayer
and the word. reflect God's character
that his name may truly be written in
your forehead and in your mind. So this
is this is what it all looks like. The
three steps to overcoming sin which
ultimately gives you the character of
Christ. And when you have Christ's
character, guess what? You're not going
to have a foul mouth. You're not going
to be lusting. You're not going to be
drinking alcohol and getting drunk.
You're not going to be trying to find
that next fix of whatever drug it is
because that's not the character of
Christ. Christ, his laws are the laws of
love, the laws of liberty. People think
this is bondage. Oh, I can't do
anything. All the things that God keeps
us from destroy our lives. He never
keeps anything good from us. I don't
know why, but God showed me that any of
these addictions are actually
Satan being like your owner and you're
the pet on a leash. Yeah. He throws a
stick, which is your addiction, and you
run after it. And he laughs and he finds
it funny that you're almost choking
yourself going after it on that leash
he's holding. And he'll hurt you so
much. And so I wanted to learn how to
put him back. I learned it was my choice
to let him own me. And so if I could,
which I knew I could eventually, it
became clear to me when you start
fighting back, you can put him in the
cage he belongs in and keep him there
and walk away and lose that key so he
can't come back on that addiction. And
so I learned how that was my goal. This
whole image actually was brought to my
mind by God of that so I could
understand what was happening.
Amen. I hope this was a blessing to you.
I hope that this was practical, that it
made the Bible seem like something
useful and real because sometimes I
think we can read it like this is just a
bunch of old stories from the past.
They're not. They're they're applicable
to our life today. If you've watched our
channel, you realize that prophecy is
coming true every single day. It's other
people's real stories of their
struggles. Yeah. And humanness, dude. We
sometimes we think that these people
were perfect stained glass people. No,
man. Peter denied Christ three times.
Those people that look like they have
the Bible under their arm and stained
glass windows and have the right suit
and they say all the right things.
They're hiding a lot of things from you.
Usually, they're ones dealing highly
with a lot of addictions and sins.
That's right. So, I pray this was a
blessing to you guys. If it was, please
give it a thumbs up. It really helps get
this video out to the algorithm. I know
there's a lot of people that need to
hear this message. If you're new to this
channel, click subscribe. We got a lot
of great videos that can open your eyes
to a lot of cool stuff um and a lot of
scary stuff and just show you that the
Bible's real. The Bible's true. Prophecy
is happening and Jesus is coming soon.
And I want to be ready. I want my
friends and family to be ready. And
that's what we're trying to show you on
this channel is how to be ready and that
we need to be ready. And if you'd like
to support this ministry, you can do so
by going to candidtruth.org. We got
multiple different ways to give there.
We don't have Patreon yet, but we might
by tomorrow. And if you like t-shirts,
we got a lot of cool t-shirts on our
shop. Go to cantruth.org. We get about
$5 commission on these shirts that sell.
And you can really wear your witness
everywhere you go. You know, people can
see, hey, what's that shirt mean? You
know what? And you can tell them, "Hey,
this is a Bible verse. Let me tell you,
it's hard to start conversations about
God sometimes about the Bible, but
sometimes that shirt you're wearing
might be exactly what somebody needed to
see. Like that was a sign, you know, and
the more you give to us, the more that
we can do with this ministry. We are
looking to hire somebody to help us get
on multiple different platforms to make
our social media presence bigger." And
um that's how we're wanting to expand.
And right now it's just us two trying to
do all this. We go on speaking
engagements. If you want to invite us to
your church, go to cantruth.org, click
booking, see our calendar, see where
we're at, what we're doing, and uh reach
out to us. We want to come and share at
your church. And right now, we got a
pastor in Kenya that wants us to come, a
group in Australia. These people can't
afford for us to come. We want to go. If
you guys feel led to uh provide for that
to happen, plane tickets, place to stay,
all that stuff, that would be a
blessing. And we'll get to speak to
people who've never heard this before.
And so, we love you guys. We thank you.
We can't do this without you. We'll see
you next time on Candid Truth.